those snacks welcome back to CBS this
morning the Democratic presidential race
has just been reshaped by a surprising
Super Tuesday Joe Biden won nine of the
14 state primaries last night including
Texas after a poor showing in the first
three contests of 2020 Bernie Sanders
won three states and holds a substantial
lead in California where it's still too
early to declare a winner Maine is still
too close to call
well this morning Biden has passed
Sanders in the all-important race for
delegates both candidates sounded
confident while addressing supporters
last night tonight I tell you with
absolute confidence we are going to win
the Democratic nomination
and we are going to defeat the most
dangerous president in the history of
this country
anyone anomaly who's a Democrat a
lifelong Democrat a proud Democrat and
we begin our coverage in California
where Joe Biden celebrated his strong
Super Tuesday showing last night Jamie
yuccas is in Santa Monica just west of
LA Jamie they gotta be feeling pretty
good in the Biden camp oh you bet
Anthony very much alive that's what
Biden is saying about his campaign to
those who wrote him off after his slow
start he pulled off some shocking
victories the biggest was Texas where
Biden spent significantly less money
than Bernie Sanders a close result means
though he'll likely split many of the
228 delegates with Sanders and Mike
Bloomberg Biden took another surprise
win in Minnesota
he didn't campaign there once but beat
Sanders in a state Sanders won heavily
in 2016
much of that is likely due to Monday's
endorsement from Minnesota senator Amy
Klobuchar exit polls there show Biden
pulled in the majority of support from
voters who made their decision on Super
Tuesday or the days leading up to it
Biden also won Massachusetts which is a
big blow to Elizabeth Warren who has not
won a single state she came in third in
her own state and finished third in
support among women in Massachusetts
behind Biden and Sanders as for Biden
the word is momentum he told CBS News
his campaign raised around five million
dollars Monday alone and about 15
million the past few days Tony all right
Jamie thank you very much